all right guys
bang bang got nelson here what's going
on man
how are you glad to have uh glad to be
here absolutely thanks so much for uh
for joining us so uh for those that
don't know
uh nelson runs a business called cadence
that uh our partners and i invested in
uh we're super super excited about uh
what they're doing in the uh in the
private credit space
so uh before we talk about that though
let's start with
just your background uh maybe talk to us
about where'd you grow up and kind of
how did you eventually
arrive at uh spending so much time in
finance
sure absolutely probably too long in
finance at this point uh but no i was
i grew up in new jersey so kind of
really close by uh have stayed in this
area my whole life
uh so first thing out of school you know
it was what 0809 ish i decided to get a
job in finance because clearly that was
a brilliant idea
at the time uh and i was there at
merrill lynch for the last two months of
maryland's life before we became bank of
america so that was fantastic
uh left that uh thinking you know
everyone's saying do the buy side buy
side's so much better than the south
side
so i joined the buy side joined
blackrock i realized that the buy side
was probably not better than the sell
side and it wasn't really that great to
begin with sellside wasn't that great
either so
uh left that thinking you know i had the
opportunity to do my own thing let's try
it see how it goes
uh and what ended up being my own thing
was really launching a strategy
consulting firm that helped startups
build and ground up
so had a lot of good case studies there
some were your portfolio companies as
well
and um you know realized that i was able
to kind of give these founders advice on
how to build companies had a team that
knew how to build products
you know a bunch of vcs realized that
you know for the right idea the right
time i should probably do it myself and
so
that's really how cadence came to be
dabbled or went into private credit
because one of our clients at the time
was almost like a private credit lender
and we saw the opportunity there and we
kind of extrapolated out a broader
vision from there so
yeah very short three-year stint in
traditional finance but a very long time
in uh
in startup finance for sure and
where did you start to kind of pay
attention to this space specifically and
like what was the impetus
for actually starting a business to
solve the problems you guys are going
after
yeah it was crazy so that client that i
mentioned who was with my old
consultancy
they were factoring purchase orders
right so they were basically saying hey
you know costco wants to buy this
from you but you need money to be able
to even manufacture those products
because you're a small
up and coming gorilla bar company or
whatever and so
i will take a haircut of six percent off
your total sale
uh recognizing that your margins are 50
and so
it's gonna be fine for you um and you
can actually manufacture the products
i get my six percent you get your win
and then you actually can you know
everybody wins in that regard uh
so that was a really interesting
opportunity we realized that
private credit and this type of lending
is really what powers the
uh kind of the global economy uh because
it's not the banks not anymore at least
they do they're very specific very large
institutional deals
but in terms of main street mom and pop
shops this is where it actually gets
done that was fascinating for me
right at least so we saw the opportunity
there but as we dug deeper and deeper
into it we realized how broken
all of private credit was there was no
transparency there was no
data around it there's no ability to
verify any transactions
it's it's a pretty opaque market
somewhat intentionally
and so if you have the opportunity to
really bring that level of transparency
to the market
you can be and facilitate the most
efficient market possible
uh in a market that desperately needs it
and so we saw that opportunity and
realized that this is the one we want to
make a business out of
let's elaborate a little bit on private
credit i think people have heard that
term before
um i've had a couple of people who've
come on and they're kind of more
uh investors in that space but we didn't
really get into like what exactly is
private credit
yeah it's a bit of a catch-all actually
uh so
you have private capital markets as a
whole which is not yours traditional
public stocks bonds etc
uh so within private capital markets
it's a wide mix you have private equity
you have venture capital you have real
estate infrastructure
and you have this catch-all called
private credit and so private credit
encompasses a variety of different
things but think of it as like
small business lending consumer loans
factory receivables
all these things that are just in kind
of like the lending space
that are smaller dollar it's it's really
what encompasses
private credit but it touches every
single thing that you do on a day-to-day
basis like that example i gave you
earlier for that
um that lender to granola bar companies
i mean you know the stuff you see at
whole foods
pretty much like all of them have gone
through some sort of private credit
transaction to even get that onto the
shelf
if they're not kashi or something like
that and so that's really where
um it's a tremendous opportunity it's a
massive market it's growing about
i think a 20 compound annual growth rate
since 2000
um it picked up during 0809 when the
bank stopped lending to the side of the
business
it's definitely picked up during kovit
when the bank's extra stopped lending to
the side of the market
uh so that's been uh one that's been an
area of significant growth
but like i mentioned earlier the
transparency part is a huge problem so
of that trillion dollars about 400
billion is sitting in cash waiting to
find deals deploying to deals
if they can literally just have a
solution for them and that's really
where we come in
got it and so the people who are
offering these opportunities
you mentioned small businesses let me
just talk a little bit about
you know kind of who's taking on um the
debt and kind of what types of
businesses are they in
why are they coming to this side of the
market rather than maybe
pursuing other types of capital
financing just just elaborate a little
bit on that
yeah sure so if you kind of go up the
chain here um so the small business
itself generally needs capital to grow
it's pretty standard um it can be backed
by it could be a secured loan it could
be an unsecured loan
if it's a secured loan it's usually off
of like a personal guarantee of the
founder of the company uh or it's like
their house or something like that
if it's unsecured it's just based off of
the um the
revenue that they're projected to
receive coming up over the next couple
months so these
businesses on a regular basis need to
take a loan out to be able to have
working capital
when things take longer to pay out and
things like that so
they usually go online they google it
because their bank probably won't lend
to them at this point these days
uh and they find the various different
you know most of them are
in tech companies actually who kind of
cover this space you're on decks or
cabbages
things like that on the small business
side um so they go to them
and they say hey you know i need a loan
for x dollars this is my financials this
is how i've done over the last couple
years
how much can you give me um and the the
lender looks at their
their client prospective borrower and
says okay i can give you this amount and
you know let's call it a day
what people don't know is that the
lender itself actually needs to get
money
themselves as well to lend out and
that's really where this entire private
credit market
is is coming from so the lenders
themselves
source capital from a variety of
different places um it could be hedge
funds it could be credit funds it could
be family offices
or even you know when they're really
small they're actually lending off their
own balance sheet so a lot of fintech
startups were backed by vcs
to get off the ground they are their
first source of capital it's
very very expensive so the
ecosystem we're helping facilitate is
basically getting the
lenders the most probably flexible
cheapest cost of capital they can get
and provided at every single phase of
their growth
because lenders ideally grow from being
a small lender to a mid-sized lender to
ultimately one that
the banks can be the ones providing
capital and that's really the holy grail
because it is the cheapest they can get
i see and so
uh based on what you've told me and i'm
cheating because uh obviously we did
really really deep analysis on the space
uh there's just a lot of fragmentation
right so it just feels like there's
people who want to give money
there's people who need the money uh
those two people have a hard time
finding each other talking to each other
sharing information
maybe just talk a little bit about like
why has no one
solved this yet yeah so it's it's a lot
of it is coming down to the fact of like
right place right time um so you had the
last couple years have been fantastic
for fintech
fintech on the infrastructure side
specifically we have all these companies
building the pipes
to better understand and analyze the
data coming out of everything that's
any transaction you're doing out of
money on the money side right so whether
you're paying for something at a point
of sale
cash register or you're trading online
or
your bank account balances like you know
plaid diwali
stripe all these guys have come out in
the last couple years and made it
significantly easier to actually capture
and analyze that data in a very
standardized way
but no one's actually kind of taken the
effort to pull that all
together and move that into part of the
underwriting process
to be able to actually aggregate all
that information understand
and have a holistic view of a borrower
of a lender whoever it is
and be able to provide it in a way that
facilitates true capital markets
transactions
and it's just kind of taken time and
time to mature
to be able for it to get there and so we
came out in
you know mid 2018-ish probably still a
little too early
for all this stuff but uh we took the
time to build out all this
infrastructure that we need to do on our
side
um to be able to actually provide that
information to help both sides find each
other right so
if a uh if a lender can provide
all the information they need to a third
party and that third party can package
it up in a way that is very
uh institutionally friendly for these
people who provide the capital to
actually diligence
find the deal and ultimately make an
investment these are things that we take
for granted in public markets
that simply never exist in private
markets especially not in private credit
and so that's really what we're we're
coming in we're taking all this
financial fintech infrastructure
uh and pulling it together to be able to
create these standards
for all things private credit got it and
so
maybe talk a little bit about um where
you started like what did the product
look like and then how has that evolved
over time to today
sure so uh what was our first initial
vision for the company
uh was just what you see on our website
right now with cadence.io
so it's pretty much a fairly standard
conventional
alternative investment marketplace you
have the ability to sign on
you can see various different
opportunities i'd like to think that
we have one of the cooler mousetraps on
the street when it comes to alternative
investments
it is the shortest duration investment
products on the market so we have one
month three-month six-month investments
we have uh probably the comparable
yields everybody else on the market in
the range of eight and a half to fifteen
percent
these days which is still pretty good
considering your cash earns nothing in a
bank
uh and you also have the lowest minimum
so it's actually the lowest bar to entry
to just try it out
and so that's allowed us to grow pretty
quickly on that front
um that was the initial vision and then
as we start to see wow these lenders
have a whole lot more problems than just
capital
um they have you know a whole situation
of either not tracking data
or not tracking data and presenting in a
way that's uh amenable to institutions
like they were hampering their own
growth simply because they didn't know
any better right they don't have capital
markets teams
dedicated towards getting them cheaper
capital as they get bigger and bigger
and so that's really when we decided to
dig deep into what the underlying
problems were
and realize that if we can create call
it this central source of truth of asset
performance data
for all these various lenders that we
work with we can help them get from
every single phase to the next phase of
their life
in a very institutionally friendly way
and so the business has evolved
dramatically from
being a you know a pretty conventional
alternative investment platform that
is comparable to other ones you can find
out there uh to
really a capital markets company um
which you don't really see much of on
our website if you were to just take a
look
got it and where did you find the first
uh you know businesses to come on and
the first investors like talk to me
about how did you actually get
in a marketplace where cat you know or
what comes first chicken or egg right
like
how did you actually get one side of the
marketplace on on
board first yeah the chicken kind of
gave birth the egg at the same time for
us like it was like almost like
simultaneously but
uh so we first you know we had some
clients in the private credit space for
my old consulting company right so we
knew that would be a good starting point
we had a bunch of people who were
friends family that worked in finance
that kind of dabbled in this space
before so we basically just reached out
to everybody and tried to see
who's a good lender who's a good
potential investor
and we said if i can make a product for
you uh that you could just invest in
very quickly very easily
uh would you invest in it and they said
yeah i mean if it's a month investment
i'm glad
you're getting 12 apy i'm glad to do
that and so
we basically ran all the various
different originators we had at that
point in time
through a pretty strict um underwriting
due diligence process
and the one that passed was when we
stuck with which is which has been a
fantastic
uh story here uh they're in the amazon
merchant working capital financing space
so basically if you're an e-comm
merchant
on amazon they'll give you capital based
upon
how much they project you to sell over
the next year um and you know they can
buy inventory with that they do whatever
they want
they can grow with that so that was our
first one did fantastically well
and on the investors side we had a
couple months to build up a user base
of investors that were honestly friends
and family we just kind of add them all
to the list
but also people who signed up from some
of the direct marketing
efforts that we had we were able to
close deals so at
january 2019 we launched our first
private beta deal
uh it closed in a couple days we thought
wow there's people that actually you
know gave us 250 000
to invest in this and you know a year
and a half later we're doing 130 million
and you know it's grown very quickly
from there but i will always remember
that
first time when someone wired us money
and i was like we might have a business
here
uh so yeah it kind of came together all
at the same time we're very fortunate
and uh obviously that original
marketplace is still
going quite strong um but now you've got
a a sash product as well so maybe talk a
little bit about kind of what this
product is and how that originated or
sure yeah so it's you know our vision is
to have that central source of truth of
asset performance data right so at the
end of the day
what that means is we need to provide
tools workflow
all these things for lenders to be able
to actually better access capital
markets
so this first sas product is designed to
essentially facilitate the servicing
surveillance that we're doing
on their data and so they're paying us a
monthly fee to be able to actually
have our team go in there and
essentially package up and understand
analyze
ingest aggregate we want to call it the
data coming through and be able to
present that
to investors because ultimately the more
transparency you give
the more comfortable investors are with
your products and the more likely
they're willing to take a lower return
because they have visibility into
performance
so that launch at the end of june was
really successful i think most of our
originators actually were on board
immediately from there so it's a great
starting point for a sas product
uh and you know the expectation is that
we can broaden that to not just the
existing
engineers we have on the retail platform
but just as a general lender product at
the end of the day got it
and so help me just get a sense um
whatever you're
comfortable sharing uh kind of publicly
where
are you guys right now right and and uh
we've kind of talked about the product
itself but from a data standpoint like
where are you so far
sure yeah so about three quarters of our
originators
uh are actually uh we're able to
actually capture ingest and analyze and
present the data on pretty much a daily
basis
and so we actually make that available
to any investor on our platform they can
see it every single day
it was we probably uh covet probably
accelerated some of our efforts on that
front uh because you had to
really get a deep understanding of how
these products were performing and how
these lenders were performing
in order to figure out whether you
continue to extend them capital or not
so the good news is overall they emerged
relatively unscathed for the most part
which is fantastic and
it was through the data that we were
able to say okay you know we can
continue with this program we can keep
it going
and if it didn't show that we would be
able to stop it
so that inevitably um you know the
short-term nature of our program allowed
us to do that
uh so i would say from a workflow
standpoint we've gotten
pretty good of an understanding of what
you know small business lending data
supposed to look like
what consumer lending data is supposed
to look like and now it's just a matter
of um
continuing to push the envelope and what
it takes to automate it what it takes to
make it more efficient
and what it takes to really create
workflow around it and that's really
what
you know we're doing with that
cadenceync that lender portal
we're launching features every week we
launched a one i think last week
around just overall documentation of all
the various different things that we
have going for them
so it is very much an iterative process
but we're making it more valuable every
single week
that we ship out new features got it and
um as you're kind of building this uh
you
went right into the teeth of a global
pandemic and an economic recession
um i think that there was probably more
people who thought you know we're late
stage of a bull market and so
this thing's gonna turn over at some
point but no one really knew when or how
severely
uh i don't think very many people at all
could predict the global pandemic
so how has that impacted the business
either positively or negatively
yeah i think it's overall for the
positive it does force your hand in a
lot of ways right like you need to react
very quickly you need to adapt
um so like i mentioned earlier we did
launch
our accelerated surveillance reporting
for more
lenders than we would have normally so
when we pre-covered we had
two lenders out of 12 that had
surveillance on a daily basis and we
ratcheted up to nine basically so
that was just the only way we were able
to get comfortable with it
but another feature that we had been
planning on launching for a while but
just kind of was on the back burner
closing deals without it uh was the
dutch auction so it was a big deal
so that came out pretty much right as
cobit hit because
in that time frame stock markets were
crashing everyone was getting margin
called they need to plot cash
we were the only i think i would say
probably one of the only platforms that
basically
every dollar that wanted to go out went
out the door right so
um we knew that we had to make up for
that shortfall somewhere
and so the truth is um at um
every asset has a price that a buyer
will come in at they just need to figure
out what that price is
that's really what this dutch auction
intended to do um so
how it works very simply is let's say
you have a lender that's willing to
take basically call it 14 cost of
capital right that's their maximum
uh we can go out to our investors and
say hey you know if we go out with 12
how much were you willing to invest 13
how much you're willing to invest 14
how much you're willing to invest and in
a if it's a normal you know conventional
investor that would say i'm willing to
do
50 grand or 12 75 grand at 13 100 grand
or 14
um and if you're investing if your
originator needs a million dollars you
figure out you know at which percentage
point do they get a million dollars
basically so when covet happened well
fortunately unfortunately
um everyone put the top line you know 14
every single time those the only way
it's gonna clear
um and so everything ratcheted up in
terms of yields
uh from like 12 to 16 to eight to 12
whatever it is um
but the beauty of of this is that as the
market stabilized
everything came down right because they
were performing they were delivering and
so
what was originally 12 jumped to 16 is
now back down to like 13
and that's fantastic right because we
were actually still able to give out
capital
when uh during that time everyone was
cutting back um so
the the pandemic forced our hand in that
regard um but
outside of that we've seen investor
demand increase dramatically
as things have started to be a little
bit more clear right so um the stock
market has defied all expectations in
terms of how it's doing
uh and so people are getting a little
wary they're you know they're like how
long can this last you know
we're seeing all this other negative
news out there and it's got to come down
at some point
and so people are looking to diversify
and so the same way that you know
crypto is diversification having bitcoin
is diversification against
as a hedge against inflation private
credit is also diversification right
it's uncorrelated
um whole foods for example still gonna
pay that granola bar company 45 days
later as per usual
um but they're not going to it's not
gonna be a situation where
they're gonna default on that and so um
it doesn't matter if stock market goes
up stock market goes down
uh that's still gonna be there so being
able to provide investors that level of
diversification
uh we've seen a lot of flight towards
our assets
and our investments as a result i see
and so
like as you go through this how
important is your access to what i'll
call
near real-time data right that's that's
one of the things that to me was so
uh impressive is um if you're in a
normal
scenario normal marketplace that data
latency
makes it really really hard to be
reactive to changes in
in the market right whether those are uh
monetary policy stuff
whether that is macroeconomic stuff just
like there's latency of information and
therefore
literally there's just latency and
response time when you have near real
time data
you can actually respond really really
quickly and so
you just described kind of the whole
idea of seeing
movement in the yield but talk a little
bit more about like how are you getting
access to that real-time data and then
how important has that been
in all facets of the business it's
probably been the most important thing
right so when you think about
all these different agreements that get
drafted for you know if you don't have x
dollars in your bank account then you
owe us this money right let's sort of
standard you know agreements that are
line items in an agreement as part of
any lender to
um or financier to a lender uh if you
don't have visibility into the bank
account
then how are you gonna verify that
you're gonna go off their word i mean
that's basically what it was for a long
time
um for the actual borrowers themselves
who need the capital from this lender
uh if you can't physically pull money
from that bank account how are you gonna
you have to wait for them to send you
checks or something like that how are
you going to verify that or get the way
for them to wire to you
it's crazy that's really how the
industry was was for a very long
time so with all this kind of
advancements
in fintech infrastructure it's been able
to facilitate a lot of this and improve
a lot of it so the data is pretty much
the core and most important thing to
what we do
it allows us to ensure that they're
always compliant it allows us to
make sure that it's performing as we
expect it to
so this daily surveillance reporting
that we create
guides every single decision we need to
make and it was extremely important
during covid
when everyone's portfolio was out of
whack basically so it's like how fast
is the um the portfolio deteriorating
uh if we can extrapolate it out like in
90 days by the end of this note what is
it going to look like
do they have enough cash to cover all
these things are things that we can see
daily and so we can react daily and we
can get ahead of it that's the biggest
thing
uh private credit before was almost like
a set it and forget it type investments
like i'll get my
quarter end reporting and hopefully it's
accurate and then if it didn't go well
then i'll have to
go you know withdraw money in the actual
redemption window
and if i miss that then i can't get it
out and so that's that's like
baffling to me when everything is
happening in real time today so we're
here we're trying to change that and
make that data available
so that people can actually make
educated decisions around these
investments
um and you can even you know mark to
market your portfolio on your own
based on the actual underlying
performance which you would never be
able to do in private credit normally
absolutely and this kind of has a nice
segue into
this fat brands deal that you guys did
uh i remember when you first started
telling me about it i was like wow
that's a pretty big jump from
kind of smaller credit opportunities
right to what ended up being tens of
millions of dollars
and you said one specific thing around
this data that just blew my mind which
was
no we can get you know near real time or
whatever the terminology used was
uh on a location by location basis
exactly what the revenue is in each
location per day
and i started just thinking like wow
that is a game changer from being able
to monitor the performance of
an asset like this and so um just kind
of give us a high level of
what was the fat brands deal how did you
guys find it how did you win it and then
kind of
how did you actually execute this sure
absolutely so fat brands is uh the
parent company of a much more well-known
thing that people may recognize which is
fat burger
so they own a couple hundred franchises
amongst a couple
of other things like i think hurricane
and ponderosa and things like that
so it's an aggregator a yum brands if
you will or an aspirational yum brand
um and they've done really well um to be
able to kind of group all these brands
together
um but they were looking for a growth
capital they wanted to actually you know
take their
company to the next level um and you
raise
debt for that basically that's like the
easiest path towards that and so they
came to us because the size is small
like
this you know the banks normally do 100
150 million dollar deals
and crowdfunding platforms do 10 million
deals and so this
kind of sweet spot of 40 million bucks
it's like who really covers that space
um because it's you know cost
prohibitive for a bank and it's probably
too big for some of the
smaller guys out there and so we stepped
up to the plate and we you know
our our vision was always that we can
graduate lenders from retail
institutional
so might as well cut our teeth on one of
the hardest transactions you can do
which is a rated whole business
securitization where
um every single dollar coming out of
each franchise's royalty
uh gets distributed out to investors in
some sort of waterfall
um so we were able to successfully close
that um because
you know we were a up and coming up
young company that had aspirations get
bigger they were willing to take a
chance with us
and we were very cost effective from a
fee standpoint because our overhead is
significantly lower than a bank
um but you know without a doubt they
definitely took a chance and believed in
us and we we owe them a lot for that uh
so we're very grateful
but yeah to your point you know this is
why companies like square and stripe are
so powerful right because they're
actually
clearing transaction data on a regular
basis they have all full visibility into
how they're
how each um machine each pos is doing or
each store is doing
and so the same way with that brands you
know if they have upgraded registers you
can actually pull that information on a
regular basis and you can see how it's
doing
and so you can start to make decisions
around um you know whether they are in
compliance
with the actual agreement that was set
in place as part of
issuing that debt um and yes that's
that's been a great transaction for us
it kind of put us on the map we're
actually uh the number 25
largest u.s structuring agent of
asset-backed securities uh in the first
half of 2020 so there are no startups on
that list so we feel very fortunate
and we are one above stifle so uh we'll
take that all day every day
um but yeah more to come on the back
half of this year we were able to
leverage that trade
to be able to kind of prove ourselves
and make a name for ourselves
in the industry uh and we've gotten a
lot of inbounds as a result of that kind
of playing in this call at 15 to 100
million dollar sector
that no one actually covers well um is a
great opportunity for us to slot in
what was the biggest thing you learned
from doing that transaction so either
biggest thing you learned or maybe the
biggest surprise
uh i think there's a reason why banks
don't do it
it's a lot of work it is definitely a
lot a lot of work
and so i can understand and see why
a bank which has you know significantly
over significant overhead costs
a headcount they have to maintain for
that type of fee structure
at a 40 million level it probably
doesn't make a ton of sense right so i
can totally see why that's the case
for a seed stage startup it's great for
us we can take that all day every day
and that's why it worked out but yeah
the team came together and it just
really pushed to be able to get this
thing done but it was what normally
would be
a half dozen people we had two
essentially
so that's that was a learning lesson for
us but it was it was good
um it was well worth it and obviously it
sounds like you're looking to do more of
those types of deals
yeah absolutely um so you know the we
have
12 13 lenders now on the platform on the
retail side uh
a couple of them are ready to graduate
and so we are going to be going out to
market
with a few of them at the institutional
level um and that's a great
case study for us to show how
originators can progress from one stage
to the next um but we have you know a
couple others that came through because
of that fat brands deal
who need the help or several hundred
million dollars who believe that
you know there's a chance that we can
help them get the capital they need at
the terms that they're looking for
um so we're pretty good on that front
and we're excited for
you know what what will happen in the
back half of 2020 as we kind of close
some of these big ticket ones out
before we get to what the kind of future
of cadence looks like
what's the pitch to investors whether
they're individuals or they are
institutions like when you go out and
you talk to them
it's pretty obvious like why originators
would want to do this right they get
access to
a pool of capital and uh it can be cost
effective for them to do that and kind
of very clean
um in a kind of a technology enabled or
data-driven way
but what's the pitch to investors like
what's that conversation like
yeah absolutely so the um
the ability for you to get access to
private credit especially a small
investor
is pretty unique so normally it's like a
half million dollar minimum
generally right and so the average
investor even their accredited or family
office doesn't necessarily want to put
that much in one deal
so for our products in particular
especially on the retail side
you have the ability to get access to
effectively institutional
caliber institutional grade deals at a
lower minimum than you would normally
see elsewhere
you get that diversification that you
want away from equities away from
you know other things you may have in
your portfolio for consistent returns
uh and you also have the ability to
actually verify how it's doing with the
data that we have
when it comes to more of the
institutional investors it's really kind
of that history that we've built with
these lenders right so they're always
looking for high quality deals if you
can give them
and be a consistent source of high
quality deals that's fantastic
um but the difference here is that we've
you know probably worked with this
lender for
months if not years we have that history
there but we also have the data around
how they're performing
and we also have it presented in a way
that every single deal you ever see from
cadence
has the cadence format right so these
small business loans always look like
this so if you've done it once it's very
easy to do diligence on it again
consumer loans always look like that
you've done it once for that you can
always do it again and rinse and repeat
so the time it takes the diligence
source and diligence of deal
goes down dramatically and a private
credit portfolio manager spends about 85
percent of time
sourcing diligence not actually
portfolio managing so
the ability for us to be able to shorten
that dramatically means they can
actually do more of their job that they
actually enjoy
um and put the money to work and the
truth is this is the 400 billion dollar
burning hole in their pocket right they
have to allocate this
they need to find opportunities we can
give it to them in a scalable way
and help them actually you know put real
dollars to work so um just being able to
get in front of them is
something that they'd appreciate uh for
the types of unique high quality
products that we have
for sure and then uh one of the things
that is fascinating to me
is the performance of these right a lot
of people would look and say okay
there's a startup so how good can they
be at underwriting this stuff and
and kind of finding high quality
opportunities the other argument is wow
they got a lot of data
and if you got a lot of data you can be
great at it uh
you guys have tended to do much better
than most but
talk a little bit about you know
defaults and kind of the quality of the
opportunities and
maybe even some of the retention of the
investors right they they've invested
and come back again
yeah for sure uh so the
the truth is um everyone that we've
hired from the capital market side came
from traditional finance right they've
actually done
asset-backed secures generally or
they've been from ratings agency or
something like that
and so they have an institutional lens
whenever they look at something like
this
and our products reflect that right we
have a lot of institutional
grade um features and bells and whistles
in there that you normally would expect
in a traditional abs
that you would never expect on a call it
a retail deal if you will
we try and layer that in to be able to
give the investors that protection
because
anything that we put on our platform we
have to be and we are confident that we
put our own money our own family's money
into it and honestly they have
so that's that's we kind of um we
put our money where our mouth is in that
regard um so
when it comes to the actual structuring
um
we've been very fortunate that
throughout covid
partially because of the short duration
nature of our products we can we were
able to reprice resize restructure
during covet
but also because the data were able to
see sort of situations arise if they
were about to arise
our default rate is about a little over
two percent uh which is
pretty much like the lowest in the
industry at this point um you have other
places that are in the 15
20 30 range and it's because they get
caught out when you have
super long dated products like three
years four years five years
you can go through an entire recession
in five years and you know you would
never know what happens that product if
you don't have the data
around it so by keeping it short we
protect uh and we
um have the ability to actually hedge
against potential risks that come out
that we may not be able to foresee
so yeah all those things together help
to create pretty much i would argue one
of the most competitive products out
there
um real institutional caliber deals made
available for at a retail level
um and we stand behind it um we put our
money in all of our deals
basically um and we actually just also
brought on board a new head of risk
who was actually the former head of
asset-backed securities and close at
morningstar
so bring another one more layer of
institutional
experience to the table and he's already
done even more
um to kind of make this even more
institutionally at institutional s
so yeah we're pushing the envelope of
that front um and
there's a there's a good reason for that
um if our retail deals are more
institutional-like
then that means that when they go to the
institutional markets they're already
institutionally ready
so everything we do on the retail side
is designed to translate to that side
you're speaking like you've got some
common sense there that is uh that's
rare sometimes in business
uh let's talk about the future of
cadence you've built a
awesome platform right obviously we're
super excited uh wanted to get behind it
and
uh invest we think that you've built a
great team where do you go from here
what is kind of the the goal or
aspiration and kind of the path to get
there
yeah we want to our goal is to
fundamentally transform private capital
markets for the better right
everything should be made more efficient
everything can be done better through
data
and so we put our flag in the ground for
private credit
as a starting point because we thought
that was probably the most opaque asset
class out of all the private capital
markets opportunities
um and it's also the one that has the
most demand so if we can
do that and we can facilitate capital
markets transaction on that front
more efficiently that we're in really
good shape so really our job
is not to be an issuer our job is not to
be a structure our job is not to be a
bank
our job is to really create create and
deliver software services and solutions
for various different stages of a
fintech lender's growth
and for all the different transaction
parties involved who can actually make
something happen here
and they can do that then we did our job
yeah
what do you think the biggest obstacles
to get there would be
probably sourcing of assets inevitably i
think um there is
a fintech lender for everybody out there
but
it's a question of how good they
actually are and so
we need to basically provide and create
something that
has and gives us the widest funnel
possible and the fastest ability to
diligence and figure out where they fit
in the funnel right like do they fit
with our retail platform do they fit
as a direct matchmaking deal do they fit
as an institutional deal or they fit
straight for the banks
it really depends right so if we can
create
software around that to be able to
capture the entire ecosystem
uh then we have that our advantage right
so we can then pick and choose to work
with from there
that is a tall order given the amount of
data that needs to be synthesized and
the amount of companies that are out
there
but it's what we're setting our sights
on right now for sure
um and then the last question before we
get into some of the rapid fire stuff
is uh when you look at what you guys
have built so far
um is there anything that you say uh
that's been
the single most important thing that we
did but we didn't anticipate that
beforehand like so kind of like
what have you guys surprised yourself
with in terms of
uh some part of the business whether
it's the business model
a piece of technology whatever that you
guys
created or built but you didn't realize
how important it would be until it was
actually in place
yeah i think um the we accidentally
stumbled into it i guess uh so the whole
concept of the short term no program
uh was the brainchild of our head of
capital markets
um and it was because he came from an
institutional
background he was at ubs that capital
markets all that
and he realized that you know no one
everyone else is doing super long data
products
and we happen to just focus on our first
um
original first few of engineers were all
short-dated anyway
so he said why don't we just make this
shorter and see how it goes
and then we were able to very quickly
get investor interest because we got all
these inbounds coming in saying hey
you know no one else is doing something
that's short this is fantastic i get
liquidity
and they were basically telling us our
value props i was like oh okay well i
guess now we know what works
um and that really has helped us
differentiate ourselves out there with
the rest of the market so
um it's think of it as like a commercial
paper desk for a fintech lender which is
unheard of because cp is normally for
like
ge or bank america or any of those guys
uh we're giving it to a fintech lender
who is a very early stage
that was great for the lender great for
the investor
and it helped us you know solve that
chicken egg problem very quickly because
everyone
uh realized they were all on the same
page and they wanted the same exact
things
yeah that's awesome uh i asked the same
two questions to everyone
uh to wrap up and then you'll get to ask
me one uh
the first is what is the most important
book that you've ever read
so this is uh probably one that has
had a lot of impact on our company as a
whole and it's required reading
but measure what matters by john doerr
so it's a
it's a fantastic read i think you know
having us having all worked in corporate
before
we realize just how painful the lack of
transparency is and lack of
accountability is for a company
and so when you have the ability to give
everyone get everyone on the same page
and everyone understands how they fit
into the broader piece of the puzzle
and they have a say in how they shape
what the quarter is supposed to look
like what the year is supposed to look
like
it's incredibly powerful so we've
iterated on and made it our own in a lot
of ways
but it serves as the framework for what
we do on a day-to-day basis to ensure
that everyone
is doing what they're supposed to be
doing and you don't need to micromanage
if they're you know delivering what they
say on that front then we're gonna have
a great quarter so
uh that's been a very impactful book for
for us as a company
that's awesome uh more fun one is second
question
aliens believer or non-believer
i think it's very egotistical to think
that there are no aliens out there
and that you know out of all the
galaxies you see in the sky and all the
planets and stars we're the only ones
that are out there so
big believer in aliens um i hope that
i'll be alive when we see our first one
but you know it's
tough to tell even where the way things
are going right now what's your take on
all the ufos
uh interesting you mean what the
pentagon released or
those videos so those are the uh
official releases but it sounds like
exactly there's more and more uh ufos
being seen every day now
yeah um i think the official releases
are probably
i don't know government like you know
next-gen technology from maybe a
different government but
um the uh yeah it's it'll be interesting
i think uh some of those have to be real
at some point it's you know just from
pure probability standpoint they can't
all be fake
um so yeah i'm a believer i love that
yeah at some point they have to be real
that's a great way to look at it uh you
could ask me one question to uh to wrap
it up here what uh what question you got
sure uh where do you
see um
the market cap of bitcoin versus gold in
2030
oh this i just tweeted this uh i think
that
bitcoin will have a larger market cap
than gold for sure
by the end of the decade um now
somebody was asking me recently is that
because i think the bitcoin market cap
is going to increase or because i think
the gold
cap is going to decrease uh obviously i
think that it is
uh um more so that the bitcoin market
caps going to increase then gold is
going to decrease
uh but but look there's an argument to
be made that you could have some uh
you know some of the market cap of sound
money enthusiast from gold leave to go
to bitcoin or whatever
um but the uh that to me isn't even like
interest like that's such like a
inevitable foregone conclusion in my
head sure
uh that the big one is just when does
bitcoin eclipse the global money supply
and like to me that's the one where
structurally
it should happen right because bitcoin
is a market expanding technology
or whatever um
much harder to nail a timeline uh
and if you're talking about ten years to
get to
you know gold market cap you basically
gotta go
let's say gold's eight or nine trillion
dollars you gotta get like 80 90 choices
you gotta get like another
10x so like you know you start talking
yeah well you just start talking about
like from a 200 billion dollar market
cap
give or take today to 8 trillion what's
that that's a
40x right yes yeah about 40x
they get another 10x you got 400x to get
to the
monetary supply like that's going to
take a while
right what do you think yeah i mean i
think i don't disagree with you on that
i think the question is going to be
what is the the actual use case and the
efficiency of that
currency and they're on transactional
basis to be able to get it to that level
right i think if it's at today's rate
it's going to be they're going to see
some challenges
but if it can dramatically improve from
a technology standpoint to be able to
actually
be comparable in terms of global money
supply then
the acceleration is going to be dramatic
in terms of just adoption uh it's just
not quite there here right now it's
gonna take a little bit of time
yeah it is definitely i think gonna be
interesting in terms of uh
kind of what's the path from here to
there um but but i've got pretty deep
confidence that uh
that we know where we're going it's just
you know we gotta figure out what road
we're taking right
at some point it'll get there as with
all things so yeah absolutely
so um before i let you go where can
people find you on the internet and
where can they find out more about
cadence
sure absolutely so our website is with
cadence.io feel free to check it out
um our customer success team was always
happy to hear from you uh you can reach
them at hello
with cadence.io uh or i'd be happy to
hear from you i'm just at nelson
with cadence.io feel free to check out
any of those places
awesome man well listen thank you so
much for doing this uh i'm obviously
very very excited about what you guys
are doing i think you're doing a
fantastic job uh not only navigating
private credit markets but also
uh with the uh pandemic and we'll have
to have you back
when uh you guys have a little bit more
progress to share so uh
keep going sounds good thanks so much
for having me